the BBC has been hit by yet another
celebrity non-scandle veteran newsreader
Hugh Edwards has been accused of paying
a 17 year old boy 35 Grand over three
years if he's got that sort of cash to
throw around BBC salaries really are out
of control 35 Grand is a lot of money
even with the cost of living crisis
soaring interest rates and rampant
inflation you could probably still heat
a one bedroom flat for a month with that
sort of cash but you wouldn't have much
left over for a few dodgy photos it's
also been alleged that he was committed
other heinous crimes such as breaking
lockdown and messaging 17 year old lands
on Instagram now this is obviously
disgusting what is a man of his age
doing on Instagram there's a place for
perverts like you mate and it's called
Facebook never ever trust a middle-aged
man who uses Instagram it's not natural
you don't belong there that's something
being turning up on love Island in a
pair of Speedos gut out with a couple of
matching nipple rings just because it's
not illegal doesn't mean it should be
allowed follow me at Francis J Foster
and one of the good guys before we found
out Hugh Edwards was a presenter in
question Gary lineker Jeremy Vine and
others came out to make it clear it
wasn't them that's how bad a track
record the BBC has when it comes to
Nancy presenters have to come out and
announce it individually that they're
not into kids you don't get that in any
other profession teachers don't pull you
aside before parents evening and go just
so you know Mr Brown your kids are
completely safe with me if you know what
I mean nights nights wink wink anyway
your daughter spelled a maths exam we're
all just glad that it isn't David
Attenborough I don't think I'd be able
to recover if I found out that he had
inappropriate relations with an underage
penguin imagine watching his
documentaries looking at the animals
they thinking that any one of them could
have been his victim just staring at a
ceiling thinking to yourself yeah I
don't know why he's got sad eyes
terrible the BBC or the institution that
gave us Jimmy Savile Rolf Harris Stuart
Hall Tim Westwood and now Hugh Edwards
my point is that just because an
institution is left-wing and publicly
funded doesn't mean it can't bring
through top tier Talent the news has
made the British public deliriously
happen we love nothing more than a
celebrity sex scandal and this one had
the added bonus of a few Glorious Days
of having to guess who the person was
it's been a fun week for all the family
and ironically one of the few successful
pieces of content the BBC has produced
in recent years now that he's been outed
the liberal intelligentia of rallying
around you saying that this is a
personal matter and it's no one else's
business if Nigel farage was out of his
announce you'd hear multiple orgasms out
of every house in Islington Garden
parties would be held in celebration and
it would be used as a reason to reverse
brexit Billy Bragg would be on the
streets with a placard saying not all
brexiteers and pedos but all pedos voted
brexit there'd be a trending hashtag on
Twitter saying nonsense for brexit and
hashtag only sex offenders want to leave
the Customs Union ospirits are only
allowed to hate two tops of individuals
nonsense and successful people if
someone is successful and an alleged
nonce that is The Sweet Spot it's at
that moment all men can take part in our
favorite pastime a ballooning bag on the
sofa looking smugly at the person next
to you and going I told you he was a
wrong one then I'll tell you there was
something dodgy about him I can spot it
a mile off it's in the eyes not a little
raisins stuck in his head Hughes brought
the nation together after the divisions
of brexit trump and covid we can all
talk about it have a beer banter and
forget for a few minutes that our
country is going down the toilet as a
great man and once said what he did was
unwise but not illegal oh and by the way
now it sounds you can hear is Phillip
Schofield breathing a sigh of relief
[Music]
foreign